I want to talk about axial precession
which is a complicated thing and it
involves rotating object so axial
precession
is where you've got an object which is
spinning and whenever you've got a
spinning object there's a strange effect
that when you try to twist it one way or
the other it never quite the axis it's
processing that the axis is rotating
about never moves in the direction
you're expecting it to and in fact
generally starts to move around like
that
here's the earth which looks like a
perfect sphere only it's not and it's
rotating and we hope we've got it the
right way around this time I'm also
going to be talking about a gyroscope if
I were to take this gyroscope and just
leave it there it's quite well balanced
and if I rotate it around and it stays
where it is if it's perfectly balanced
nothing moves and now just let me move
this thing
this extra weight so this is unbalanced
and then you can see the effect of
changing the balance if I put it there
this will drop down it will oscillate in
a very simple-minded way just like a
pendulum so now let me rotate this and
everybody seeing this will imagine that
the effective rotation is just to let
this drop down but it doesn't do that it
doesn't do that at all
this motion round is called precession
it precesses around this axis so i'm
going to call it axial precession and
you can see that it's rotating round and
a finite rate which is fairly slow but
if I made this come further out and put
more force on it it would go a little
bit faster so this is an effect due to
the fact whoops that this is trying to
push it downwards but as it's trying to
push it downwards with no counter
balancing force on the other side it
actually goes the other way it starts
spinning that way the trouble is you
tend to look at a spinning object and
think of it as just kind of a single
entity and actually of course what's
going on is there's different bits of it
that are all actually moving around in a
circle
so there's actually quite a complicated
system here at different bits all
rotating around and really when you try
and then change the orientation of the
thing you're trying to change a whole
bunch of different objects and make them
all move to different places of move in
different directions well that the
direction it rotates in depends on
whether I make it go that way on the
other way so if I spun it the other way
it would have I got it the other way I
probably got it the same way
I got it go the other way then it will
rotate backwards so the direction of
this rotation has a big effect if it
goes the other way it will process in
the opposite direct
so the question then is is there any
effect like that on the earth so if I
take this sphere one question that arose
early on is because of the spinning of
the earth is it squashed at the poles
and fatter at the equator or is it
elongated at the poles or prolate
ellipsoid they call it and narrow it the
and people really didn't know the answer
to this Rene Descartes predicted that it
was going to be fatter at the poles
whereas Newton worked out that a
spinning object would be fatter at the
equator the French Academy of Sciences
in 1715 sent an expedition to Peru
somewhere over here near the equator and
to Lapland somewhere up there near the
pole to see if there was a difference
and they came back did the experiment
over ten years and worked out it was
fatter at the equator in other words the
earth is not as it's here
but it's got a bit of blue tack an extra
bit of bulge around the equator if you
have a perfectly spherical spinning
object then he won't actually process at
all because there's really no difference
as you as you reorient it it doesn't
really change at all but because the
earth is slightly oblate it's slightly
squashed that means that if you reorient
it you're actually kind of changing the
configuration of the whole earth and so
the earth is a spinning Norman spiracle
object and that means that when you try
and twist it the axis that it's rotating
about will start to process around so
because it's spinning it doesn't want to
go that way it wants to waggle around
very slowly like this this is called the
axial precession of the earth now that
is quite amazing but even more amazing
is the fact that there was a Greek guy
who in about 120 BC measured it Newton
was the one who actually understood what
the effect was but in fact the
measurement of the effect the amazement
of this procession goes back much
further than that there's some argument
about who the first person who actually
made the measurement actually was but it
seems likely that one of the first
reliable measurements was actually
Hipparchus in about 150 BC who did this
very clever thing of measuring the
positions of the stars relative to the
Sun
at a particular on a particular date and
then compared them to previous
measurements that are already been made
and showed that actually on that date
the stars weren't in the same position
relative to the Sun it's a bit of a
tricky one because of course you want to
measure the position of stars relative
to the Sun but of course if you want to
see the Stars the sun's not usually
around because you see stars at night
and if you want to see the Sun stars
aren't usually around because you can't
see the stars during the day so but he
had this very elegant way of doing it
which was that he waited for a lunar
eclipse which is when the earth comes
between the Sun and the moon and and so
when this Aluna Eclipse you know that
these three planets are exactly in
alliance or two planets and the Sun are
exactly in a line and that means if the
moon's over there you know that the Sun
has to be 180 degrees away in completely
the opposite direction so what he do is
waited for this lunar eclipse then
measured the positions of stars relative
to the moon and then just added 180
degrees to his measurement and that told
him how far that star was away from the
Sun on the sky the other important point
is that the earth isn't completely
spherical if the earth were really a
completely spherical object then you
could actually just change its
orientation and none of these
processional effects would occur the
Bulge at the equator comes from the idea
that this is rotating when I when I
lived in New York when I was a young lad
they used in the Italian restaurants get
bits of dough and stand in the window
and they twirl it around and throw it up
in the air and the more they threw it up
in the air the more it spread out well
here you've got the earth and it's not a
piece of pasta and you can't throw up in
the air nicely but if you were to and
it's spinning around fast enough you can
imagine that the sort of centrifugal
forces will pull it out at the equator
and squash it down top and bottom so
what actually happens is that the earth
instead of instead of actually tipping
up starts to process around so that the
the axis of the earth slowly moves
around in sort of absolute coordinates
but because the forces involved are
actually very small and the Earth's mass
is very large the time scales are very
long it processes on a time scale of
about 26,000 years later about 26,000
years for the Earth's axis to process
around if it weren't this squash sphere
it would then rotate and it would act as
though all forces acted in the middle
and it's this small no
spiracle nature of the earth which leads
to this axial precession so although in
in qualitative terms to sort of
understand what these talks do and so on
is relatively straightforward the
mathematics is rather more complicated
and of course the other thing that
complicates things is in the solar
system for example the earth and the
moon and the Sun are not always in the
same orientation so sometimes you know
the Earth's on one side of the moon and
the sun's on the other side of the earth
so they're all you know obviously
different ways around sometimes the Sun
and the moon both on the same sides of
the earth so the even this talk affect
how the earth is being tucked around
changes with time and that leads to a
whole nother thing this whole thing
called mutation which is there are sort
of shorter term wiggle with wobbles of
viewer's axis on sort of timescales of
eight years that are then superimposed
on this long time scale 26,000 year
effect